[Musique]
dans le cycle de l'eau la station
d'épuration assainies l'eau polluée par
nos usages
ainsi cette journée mondiale est
l'occasion de comprendre une partie de
nos actions sur cette denrée vitale
l'eau
si vous voulez faire une vous avez
vraiment il est légèrement compliqué on
ne peut pas s'échapper
vous avez des canalisations et
initié au métier
les mauvaises odeurs confie théâtre à
l'extérieur je vais demander entre vous
de faire les témoins david est venue
avec ses enfants qui font la visite avec
l'autre groupe en famille avec mes deux
enfants
donc pareil qui visitent aussi de leur
côté
on verra bien ce que ça donne ça sang
comme en ont en effet sas en face en
wiiware dans les égouts ça sent les
échos la différence de hauteur entre la
l'extérieur créé l'interview c'est
vraiment flagrant
pourquoi visiter une cg d'épuration
c'est bizarre
non non c'est pas byzance et ça fait
partie de l'environnement
l'environnement aujourd'hui quand même
un point important de la vie hein je
désirais ma main un critère à prendre en
compte si on veut continuer à rester à
cette planète là c'est vrai qu'on
prendrait le principal moteur de ces
visiteurs d'un jour quelques éléments
pédagogiques sur une station d'épuration
avec le directeur des lieux
ici au grand prado on va avoir toute une
étape de prétraitement ce qu'on appelle
les pré traitement dont l'objectif est
d' enlever tout ce qui est élément
solide donc on va enlever des gros
déchet par une étape de dégrillage on va
enlever tout ce qui est sable et on va
enlever tout ce qui est grèce donc c'est
auprès tt vous ensuite partir dans des
bassins qu'on appelle des bassins
narration qui constitue le coeur du
système
donc pour faire simple ce sont des micro
organismes vivants qui vont manger la
pollution qui vont donc dégradé la
pollution contenus dans les eaux usées
en les eaux qui vont sortir traité de
l'assassin de curation sont complètement
dépolluer de leur pollution et donc
peuvent être rejetés au final dans le
milieu naturel la visite se poursuit à
l'extérieur mais au même moment
plusieurs stations de l'île ouvrent
leurs portes aux citoyens qui découvre
la face cachée de la dépollution des
eaux
un des objectifs majeurs de l'office de
l'eau un établissement financé par le
département
don qui permet de rendre accessible
l'information au public donc le rôle de
l'office de luz et aussi vulgariser
l'information notamment sur les stations
d'épuration l'assainissement à la
réunion on a en a réalisé énormément de
travaux donc les collectivités depuis
2010 on construit 14 stations
d'épuration donc ce qui est énorme sur
sa station existante mais globalement la
capacité est bonne et donc permet de
répondre à la fois aux besoins
de collecter les eaux ménagères mais
également certaines activités
industrielles
chaque jour l'équivalent de 20 piscines
olympiques sont assainis pour exemple
l'office de l'eau à financer à hauteur
de 5,9 millions d'euros cette station et
1,9 million d'euros pour le raccordement
une politique d'équipement des
différentes communes qui a du sens à ses
nerfs les océans entre +1 les eaux
rejetées à l'environnement et ça
participe à la préservation de la
qualité de l'eau mais également la
préservation de l'environnement
comme on dit les petits bébés qui vivent
dedans et également ce après ça permet
également de pouvoir utiliser cette eau
propre des usages tels que l'irrigation
les industriels donc ça permet de
réduire concrètement les besoins en
termes de traitement pour utiliser cette
retour à sainte marie où les deux
groupes se rejoignent
david a retrouvé ses enfants mais avec
une autre vision du monde qui les
entoure j'ai appris comment les eaux se
font traiter où elles vont après elles
sont pas directement potable elles vont
dans la mer et une partie reste là pour
arroser les plantes s'occuper de la
station on prendrait la première étape
pour limiter l'impact environnemental et
par ricochet les factures l'avenir sera
donc fait de choix un partage collectif
de la préservation de cette ressource
vitale
[Musique]
du coup